do you remember this paper less than two
weeks old it made Waves by concluding
that open source models can mimic the
style but not the factuality of chat GPT
overall we can conclude they say that
model imitation is a false promise well
48 hours ago we have this a 51-page
report on Orca based on a small 13
billion parameter model I don't often
comment on open source models because
they're simply not competitive with open
ai's models but Orca is not just
competitive with GPT 3.5 it beats it in
quite a few well-established benchmarks
and even matches gpt4 in a couple of
tests of reasoning as always I've read
both papers in full and can also bring
in just release comments from Sam Altman
and Ilya satsukova on competition from
open source models but let's start with
Orca named presumably because orcas or
killer whales are frequent visitors to
South American coastlines and South
America is of course the land of llamas
and vacunas but all the research was
done by Microsoft which I find
interesting and I'll come back to that
at the end but why did they make Orca
and why does it perform better than
models like llama alpaca and vicuna well
they say here in the abstract that those
other models lack rigorous evaluation
resulting in overestimating the small
model's capability as they tend to learn
to imitate the style but not the
reasoning of lfm's large Foundation
models to address these challenges we
develop Orca a 13 billion parameter
model that learns to imitate the
reasoning process of the larger models
Orca learns by looking at gpt4's
step-by-step thought processes and is
Guided by teacher assistance from Chachi
PT which is GPT 3.5 and to give you a
taste of what's to come Orca surpasses
conventional state-of-the-art models
such as vikuna by more than 100 in
complex zero shot reasoning benchmarks
like the big bench hard which I'll talk
about and by 42 on AGI eval it goes on
Orca reaches parity with Chachi PT on
the big bench hard and shows competitive
performance in professional and academic
examinations by the SAT LSAT GRE and
GMAT and I know many of you will be
interested in this footnote we are
working with our legal team to publicly
release a diff of the model weights in
accordance with llama's release policy
so if this is anything like llama it's
going to be leaked across the internet
imminently I'm going to show you so many
tests and benchmarks in a moment but
just to give you a sample here is orca
outperforming Chachi PT in the vicuna
evaluation set and matching text DaVinci
3 in the SAT LSAT GRE and GMAT and as
I'll touch on later this was Zero shot
without Chain of Thought or any advanced
methods you can watch pretty much any of
my other videos to see how advanced
prompt engineering would probably boost
those results still further for those
who didn't know 13 billion parameters is
about seven percent the size of GPT 3
which is 175 billion parameters and
possibly around one or two percent of
gpt4's size that gives you an indication
of the difference in size between Orca
and these models that it's competing
with and if that doesn't make any sense
a smaller size means it can be run on
much smaller devices like a desktop or
even possibly a laptop the authors start
off by giving a little slap to the other
paper you know that one that said model
imitation is a false promise and they
continue that contrary to this assertion
it is possible to reduce the Gap with
proprietary llms on multiple zero shot
benchmarks that require sophisticated
reasoning as we'll see models like
vicuna claim to have 90 of chat gpt's
quality but when it came to reasoning
tasks or more technical tasks it
basically flopped here's a chart I'll
come back to outlining some of the more
technical challenges you can give a
language model we should remember that
vicuna is a fine-tuned version of the
Llama model and it's competitive or even
better than Palm 2 but give it some of
the harder challenges for a language
model and it really struggles as you can
see in this column take logical
deduction where it only scored 1.2
percent well this awkward model was 2
900 better than that scoring 36 percent
competitive with Chachi BT I'm going to
come back to the big bench Benchmark but
look for a second at causal judgment
where Orca a 13 billion parameter model
matches gpt4 which is about a hundred
times the size but back to how they
actually did it models like alpaca and
vicuna were given lots of query and
responses from chat GPT or gpt4 but what
they did is they leveraged system
instructions asking models like gpt4 and
chat GPT to think step by step this gave
Orca access to detailed responses from
the model that explain the reasoning
process of the teacher as it generates
the response it allowed these parent
models of gypsy 3.5 and gpd4 to be much
better tutors for this young Orca also
they let the teachers of Chachi PT which
is 3.5 and gpt4 give far more examples
to their student 5 million and 1 million
examples respectively that compares to
the other models you may have heard of
like alpaca wizard vicuna Etc which had
tens of thousands or the low hundreds of
thousands of examples but again the key
difference is the explanations the
step-by-step thinking that the smaller
Orca could then imitate they give a
quick demo here of how the other open
source models learn from their GPT
parents with a simplistic question and
answer format in contrast the author's
leverage system messages to get chat gbt
and gpc4 to think step by step leading
to much richer explanations as you can
see in this diagram it wasn't just let's
think step by step by the way also
things like explain like I'm five they
also wanted the task to be as complex
and diverse as possible so they used the
flan collection this was released by
Google in February and focused on
balancing the kind of prompts and tasks
that you fine-tune the language models
on you can see here the 16 system
messages that they give to Chachi PT and
gpt4 and you can see here the kind of
difference that that makes imagine a
language model trying to learn from this
human the human is asked pick which
sentence is not logical sentence a
people in the desert often look forward
to flood or sentence B people in the
desert often look forward to rain the
human responds there is no reason to
look forward to a flood because floods
cause damage the answer is sentence a
now yes a language model can learn from
that but by leveraging those system
assistant messages look at the kind of
response that gpd4 gives now Orca can
learn a lot more from that explanation
and that's why one of the main reasons
it's better than all the other open
source models because remember vicuna is
the best of the open source models in
this leaderboard it has an ELO of 1054
better even than Palm 2 Bison all the
models higher than it are proprietary
but there is another reason why Orca
performs so much better you might have
wondered why didn't they just use only
gpt4 well yes there were cost and time
considerations but there was another
factor that they found they were able to
use chatty PT or GPT 3.5 as an
intermediate teacher that teacher
chattybt was able to reduce the Gap in
capabilities so Orca got smarter and
better able to learn a bit like
Progressive learning where you first
learn from easier examples than followed
by harder ones after that they gave it
outputs from gpt4 notice by the way what
happens if you skip the chat TPT
teaching assistant and only train on
those 1 million examples from gpd4 what
happens is a bit like a student
struggling in class that's too advanced
for them Walker actually performs worse
in those circumstances averaging 37 but
with that intermediate teacher
beforehand it gets 41.7 speaking of time
it only took about 200 hours to train
Orca on 20 a 100 gpus they did take a
few weeks to collect the data from chat
GPT and gpt4 but presumably if they're
planning to open source this which they
say they are then that step could be
skipped by The Wider Community let's now
look at some more of the results first
for open-ended generation not multiple
choice Orca is 95 of chat GPT quality
and 85 percent of gt4's quality as
assessed by gpt4 but they wanted to
quickly move on to some more definitive
tasks because there is a problem of
using Gypsy 4 as an assessor for example
they observe that there is a positive
bias in GT4 evaluation toward the
response of the first model in the
comparison set this reminded me of the
Unfaithful reasoning paper that I talked
about in one of my recent videos you
can't always trust gpt4 to give its true
reasoning but here it is in more
objective multiple choice questions and
notice how much harder many of these
tests are for even these Advanced
language models I am fortunate and proud
to have attained a perfect score in some
of the tests in this chart like the GRE
and GMAT they were part of the aqua rat
test that they gave the models so I can
say that they really are quite
challenging hence why GT4 only gets a 40
but you can see that throughout Orca
outperforms vicuna by quite a margin and
is very competitive with text DaVinci 3.
of course overall it does lag behind
gpd4 but this is all the zero shots a
bit later on I'll come back to the range
of methods that we could use to further
improve on Orca the percentages by the
way are the improvements on vicuna again
the second best open source model so far
we've looked at human-centric benchmarks
like the GMAT and GRE these are grouped
with the lovely name AGI eval and as
we've seen even the top models lag
behind the top human performers but what
about a benchmark specifically for
language models it's called Big bench
hard the original big bench had 207
tasks but language models got so good
that they had to narrow down the
Benchmark to just the 23 challenging
tasks where human raters still did
better than language models now it turns
out when you add Chain of Thought
prompting to the models they do even
better and there are even fewer tasks
that humans are better at but anyway all
you have to remember is that these are
23 of the hardest tasks for language
models and I'll just let you compare the
results for yourself but the trend is
really quite clear Walker massively
outperforming the previous best open
source model vicuna beating even chat
GPT on average but still of course
lagging behind gpd4 except for a few
tasks look at Web of Lies where Orca
outperforms gpt4 that would be a a
question like this Alexis says Shonda
tells the truth Jim lies Antoine says
Jim tells the truth Shonda says Antoine
lies does Alexis tell the truth or what
about Temple sequences where Orca
absolutely crushes vicuna and doubles
chatty PT's performance that would be a
situation like this now I'm not going to
read it all out but essentially you have
to figure out when the timings match up
basically keeping track of time and orca
does really well and chat TPT flops
getting it wrong interestingly they also
tested all four models on that Common
Sense reasoning question that I
demonstrated for smartgbt about hanging
the clothes to dry as you might remember
you can use prompt engineering to nudge
the models to almost always get it right
which is partly why I view these results
more as a baseline rather than a cap and
the authors admit this too Orca has been
trained on data that simulate zero shot
setting with standard prompts the
model's performance in other contacts
such as multi turn conversations like
the dearer paper I talked about on the
channel in context learning and few shot
learning or Advanced prompting
techniques that smart GPT or tree of
thoughts for example and they say like
Chain of Thought prompting remains
untested these results are a baseline
not a cap they mention other ways that
Orca could be improved for example
through tool augmentation and that's not
just calculators calendars Bing or Auto
GPT I was going to do a separate video
on this paper but I'll just mention it
here this paper from last week
demonstrated that larger models can
create tools that smaller models can
then use more efficiently once the best
language models say gpt4 has created a
generic python function which is the
tool and then written some unit tests it
can then wrap and hand over those tools
to smaller models like Gypsy 3.5 or in
this case awka and check out the tool
making row to see the Improvement for
chat GPT or in our case Orca when
they're given these tools created by
gpt4 or better language models their
performance across a range of tasks goes
dramatically up and we haven't even
talked about using a process based
reward model like in the let's verify
step-by-step paper that of course could
further improve orca's performance of
course when this model becomes publicly
available I will test all of this out
but it hasn't been open sourced yet and
they do say this model is solely
designed for research settings that does
seem a little bit naive to me I mean
that's what meta said when they released
llama but then everyone and their
grandma just use their language model
for whatever I do wonder what it means
when they say we are working with our
legal team and it is particularly
interesting to me that this was all done
by Microsoft I'm going to go into a
little bit of speculation here about why
I think they conducted This research you
might remember that leaked Memo from
Google we have no modes and they even
mentioned vicuna and talked about how it
circumvented restrictions on the open AI
API by use using share GPT and my theory
is that the Microsoft researchers were
testing this point from the memo the
point was that training giant models
from scratch not only throws away the
pre-training but also any iterative open
source improvements that have been made
on top doesn't take long for those
improvements to dominate making the full
retrain extremely costly maybe Microsoft
is hesitating about future investments
in GT5 or gpd6 and they really want to
test out if it's easy to imitate those
large models on the cheap if it is then
why would Microsoft invest billions in a
new giant model that's my own Theory as
to why Microsoft is working on this but
let me know in the comments what your
theory is in the conclusion the authors
state that Orca suggests that learning
from step-by-step explanations could
significantly improve the quality of
models regardless of their size and that
they hope these insights will inform the
design of more robust evaluation methods
compared to those used for vicuna for
example and the advancement of alignment
and post training techniques and the
more effective use of powerful models
like gpt4 as teachers and maybe they
should have said and also with chatgpt
as an intermediate teacher I'm going to
end with the thoughts of the leaders of
openai Elia sotskova and Sam Altman on
open source models and I think there is
a bit of a contrast between the two
answers Ilya satsukova thinks that the
Gap is growing ever wider to the open
source versus non-open Source models
question
you don't want to think about it in in
binary black and white terms where like
there is a secret source that you'll
never be rediscovered
what I will say or whether gpt4 will
ever be reproduced by open source models
perhaps one day it will be
but when it will be it will be a much
more powerful model in the companies
so there will always be a gap between
the open source models and the private
models
and this Gap may even be increase in
this time the amount of effort and
engineering and research that it takes
to produce one such neural net keeps
increasing and so even if there are open
source models they will never be they
will be less and less produced by small
groups of of dedicated researchers and
engineers and it will only be the
Providence of a company
big company while some Altman seems to
say that even if open source models do
catch up open AI will always have a
different kind of modes what are your
thoughts about the we have no modes
document that was released lately
a leaked document I
the the thing that is special about open
Ai and I think the thing that is so
misunderstood by that document aside
from the fact that we have like a
gigantic number of users and people that
alike have formed some sort of
relationship with us and our products is
what openai is special about is figuring
out what comes next it is the ability it
is easy to copy something once you know
it can be done and in that sense sure it
is very hard to go figure out what to do
next and the idea is the Big Ideas the
medium size ideas the small ideas and
the careful execution on them that it
takes to get from here to Super
intelligence that's what our mode is
anyway this video could have been at
least three times longer there was so
much I had to edit out for brevity if
you're interested in me talking more
about Open Source models do let me know
in the comments I've got much more to
say as always thank you so much for
watching to the end and have a wonderful
day